hello everyone this next game is
definitely a romantic one as it's not
the kind of often seen in modern chess
and it was 13 2015 between the Chinese
superstar Yee against the the Cuban
Grandmaster was our Baptista brew zone
and well it's a pretty theoretical game
and this game has been played before but
the novelty way you prepare for this
game is simply brilliant and I'm sure
I'm sure you all enjoy it
whyyyy is white and bruised own is black
we have E 4 C 5 the Sicilian defense
Knight to f3 d6 Knight to c3 a 6-bit
three two nice a c6
d4c captures on d4 Knight captures Queen
to c7 so pretty standard Castle Knight
to f6 Bishop to e3 Bishop to e7 f for d6
into h1 castles and now Queen to e1
preparing to go to g3 and my captors on
d4 Bishop captures on d4 and lv v queens
the g3 Bishop to b7 and now a three
preparing I mean protecting from anybody
for ideas and notice that this e4 pawn
cannot be captured because if the knight
ever moves and simply what Queen
captures on g7 is checkmate so rocket 88
we have route 81 rope the d7 Bishop to
d3 Queen to d8 Queens the h3 and way is
now threatening well this h7 square the
thread is e5 and this has to be
protected somehow so for someplace g6
and when he goes f5 and this F file is
still well pretty theoretical as this
game was played before so we have e 5
Bishop to e3 rook to e8 and this was
also played we have a F Kesterson g 6h
captures and g6 and this is the novelty
that's where he prepared in this
position he played nice to d5 and well
okay the Knights can be captured and it
seems like black is winning upon here
but what the Brisson played was a knight
captures on d5 and this is actually what
the computer suggests
but now why he has this beautiful attack
that well starts starts a magnificent
King hunt
he plays a rook captures on f7 and there
is a thread of Queen Queen to h7
checkmate
so the rock has to be captured King
captures rook and Queens rate seven
check and here we have a king to e6 and
now he captures on d5 we have King
captures on d5 because if the mission
which was capture on d5 then Bishop
captures and g6 with the threat of Queen
Queen to f7 and Queen the bishop that
five check so after each after some d5
skin cancers and e5 is played and now
well the the attack definitely has to be
continued to have to lure the King
deeper into the possession because if
the King can go to c6 and c7 the attack
is over
so we finds a very nice idea he plays
Bishop the e4 check and now he pulls the
King deeper into the position we have
King captures on e4 and now Queen to f7
and this is a very nice silent move of
guarding this d5 square so the King
can't run away and well way is actually
interesting all sorts of different
checkmates here well the most obvious
one is Queen to f3 checkmate
but other than Queen to f3 any move the
bishop mix is checkmate
so Bishop to c5 e checkmate Bishop to b6
is checkmate a7 F to G 1 so pretty much
everything but this B form
d4 square okay so this has to be
defended and resumed plays the only move
which is Bishop to f6 and now we have a
bishop to d2 which check King goes to d4
and now a repetition of moves Bishop to
e3 and the King three four I think we
was probably trying to see if Brazil
would go to that fight with the king
so we find a nut right here he plays
Queen to b3 and well now this is also
very dangerous
and the thread is obviously Queen to d3
and this has to be starts only move to
stop visit the stopping this is the King
to f5 and now we have erupted the f1
check King to g4 and now Queen to d3
now with the ideas of Queen 2e to check
and hear well it's really hard to defend
against all the threats and Brazil tries
a bit of caster Sanji to with check well
King capture Sanji - and now Queen 2a8
checking the White King we have a king
to G one Bishop to g5 and now Quinta e
to check King goes to h4 we have a
bishop to f2 check King has to go to h3
and now we finished the game beautifully
with a bit of movie plays Bishop t1 and
in this position was our war zone
resigned as there is no defense defense
against well also subject mates here for
example if Queen to d5 and simply a rope
to f3 check and after for example kinked
g4 Queens g2 check King to h5 and our
rotation 3 checkmate but any other move
black plays it well it leads the to
checkmate so yeah definitely a beautiful
game and after this night to defy let's
just see one more time how this King
goes down the board so a beautiful King
hunts that well is a very rarely seen in
modern chase like I said and there it
goes ok but in this position but these
are resigned so yeah I hope you enjoyed
this game I think way you was 16 years
old at the time this game was played and
he didn't win the tournament at he got
fourth place but still a fantastic
result so yeah that's it I think all for
watching as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and I'll see you
soon